so what Hogwart house does your favorite
Disney character belong in today we're
playing at being the Sorting Hat and
deciding will it be Gryffindor or do
they actually belong in Slytherin Elsa
is a bit of a tricky one to sort out to
be honest some might be tempted to place
her in Slytherin considering how
questionable her motivation seems but
when you really get down to it she is
totally devoted to her sister and
because of this we would have to place
her more with Hufflepuff seriously her
loyalty goes to such extremes that she's
even willing to isolate herself against
the world completely all to keep on us
safe Elsa wait no I'm just trying to
protect you not only that but she's
hard-working and loyal to Arendale as
their Queens so while studying at
Hogwarts Elsa would definitely do well
in a transfigurations class seeing as
she's already great at bringing plain
snow to life